[Musik]
hab ich leider blume alte scott king of
schnitzel sigmar gabriel seinen job bei
tennis im verhältnis zu dem womit
während sonst beschäftigen ist es ja
fast ein heiteres thema was hat
natürlich einen ernsten kern sigmar
gabriel der ja mal echten bedeutender
und finde ich auch ganz interessanter
und wichtiger spd-politiker war für den
fall dass das überhaupt geben kann hat
einen nebenjob gehabt bei jennys ja das
sind die kollegen die 50.000 schweizer
am tag schlachten und dabei nicht so
ganz genau hingucken wie es den
schweinen geht und ihren mitarbeitern
drei monate lang weiß ich nicht 10.000
euro jeden monat und alle wissen hat
tennis kann auch gute gehälter jetzt war
es war lustig wenn es sein muss ja das
war und in kürze das jetzt oder nie aber
ich habe mich verbrannt ich mal
folgendes ich zehn von zehn runter und
bei vier oder so kommt der
rassismusvorwurf ist es das worauf sie
hinauswollen
was also irgendwie ja irgendwas was man
wirklich nochmal umhängen kann damit
jetzt unterhalte schwein geschlachtet
und anja nicht keine ahnung aber ich
meine die die die idee inbrunst möchte
ich sagen das tempo mit dem sigmar
gabriel für diesen beratervertrag den er
gleich zwei monate lang hatte jetzt
geschlachtet wird also im übertragenen
sinne geschlachtet wird
er kann sich mit also ein team schlacht
tempo bei harniks alle male messen so
viele räume ich ein
aber jetzt regt sich durch die
gesammelte sozialdemokratie und noch der
rest des publikums von links bis rechts
oben unten darüber auf dass sigmar
gabriel nicht nach seinem abend im
bundestag wurde das war mein letztes amt
quasi in hartz4 gefallen ist oder früher
rente beantragt hat der arbeit hat die
ehemalige außenminister der er ist und
ehemalige bundesvorsitzende der spd und
mitglied des deutschen bundestages
meinen sie daher war der absturz in
hartz 4 unmittelbar bevorstand weiß ich
nicht ganz genau auf die mail hatte er
noch eine gewisse karenzzeit weil er
noch ein junger politiker ist und nicht
an seinem amt geklebt hat ist dass er
auch mit den füßen zuerst aus dem
bundestag herausgetragen worden ist wie
so manch anderer hat er noch ein
bisschen zeit die wir geld verdienen
muss bevor er seine rente bekommt sein
kleine provision und es ist eben
also ist aber klassiker also sieben
entschuldigt ich kann ja auch das recht
sich absprechen geld zu fragen
der kann doch alles was ihr in der
krankenversorgung sony und polemik mal
ganz groß raus natürlich muss jeder
politiker wenn er mit der politik
aufhört irgendwas anderes machen können
danke ja im namen des deutschen volkes
und aller politiker sage ich danke
ok also einfach wie man als englisch
sagt staging mit bleeding ob wir es
einfach das was e class noch einmal
aussprechen
yahoo zweitens gibt es nicht umsonst
seit 2005 10 seit ein gewisser herr
pofalla an den der an oder haben sie
sich noch erinnern will bestimmte regeln
dafür die auch qualifiziert sind wann
man was machen darf und wer dann darüber
entscheidet ob das eigentlich okay und
wie lange das dauert so genannte
karenzzeit und so trifft für gabriel
nicht zu oder beides gelingt hat er sich
daran gehalten hat er sich daran
gehalten
drittens gibt es neben einigen konnten
sie jetzt mal die vorwurfs landschaft
gibt es nicht mal im ansatz so was wie
anstand und tennis hast kein anstand
dieser drehen ob und tennis war schon
jetzt kein tennis war schon vor corona
kein anständiges unternehmen ehrlich
gesagt wusste jeder mensch der sich mit
diesen arbeitsbedingungen in diesen
großschlachtereien beschäftigt hat
einmal nur oberflächlich was das für
eine sauerei ist und gerade und das ist
natürlich jetzt entschuldigung damit
herum dass gerade ein sozialdemokrat
zumal ein ehemaliger bundesvorsitzender
der sozialdemokratie jemand der seiner
eigenen partei vorgeworfen hat dass sie
nicht dahin geht wo es stinkt ja ewiges
zitat von gabriel er ist dann eingang wo
es stinkt hat dann aber festgestellt
geld stinkt nicht und hat es dann
trotzdem mitgenommen
das ist einfach nicht gut das ist das
ist jetzt okay ich habe jetzt verstanden
ist ein moralischer vorwurf er hätte
dort nicht arbeiten dürfen vom
moralischen vorwürfen erhalten sie
nichts zu sagen gehabt doch überhaupt
nicht zuständig da gehe ich nein nein
nein sie hier kollege aufstellen und
erleben sie ihre niederlage live mit
ihrer argumentative niederlage natürlich
gibt es moral und anstand natürlich gibt
es sachen die sollte man nicht machen
ich finde zum beispiel dass gerhard
schröder ehemaliger bundeskanzler noch
etage höher deutlich hinter
der sollte seinen marktwert seien auch
seinen nachwirkenden amtsbonus dem er
als bundeskanzler in der welt schon so
hat nicht bei herrn putin zu markte
tragen
das finde ich zb das halte ich für
unanständig für eine firma zu arbeiten
dessen produkte legal sind
dessen arbeitsbedingungen leider auch
legal rein denn da liegt der hase im
pfeffer oder das schweinehälften die die
verfahren der angewöhnt hat die
bedingungen die er gestellt hat waren
allesamt legal wäre sie ändern möchte
soll sie verdammt noch mal ändern aber
nicht den man vorwerfen dass er sich im
rahmen der regeln sie ihn gesetzt bei
der atomenergie arbeit oder ball oder
bei kraussmaffei in der
waffenherstellung oder bei tommys
irgendwie wo die wo die schweine echt
unter unmenschlichen bedingungen
geschlachtet werden entschuldigung darf
unseren nachher essen also jetzt auch
moralisch und dann nachher sagen er
wieso es war alles legal hier ist dass
alles legal
das erste zeigt es nur was für sauereien
bei uns legal sind und das hätte er als
als spd-politiker der in
regierungsverantwortung war viele jahre
auch vielleicht mal ändern kann
witzigerweise hatte er es geändert und
sie sind einfach eine eine nahtlose
planstelle was recherche angeht er hat
es geändert nämlich als ich glaube als
wirtschaftsminister und als arbeitsloser
weiß nicht mehr ganz genau hat er die
diese industrie glaube ich sogar als
schweine industrie bezeichnet und dann
eine freiwillige selbstverpflichtung der
hätten der produzenten darunter tennis
erwirkt eine freiwillige
selbstverpflichtung ob diese wirklich
etwas das schärfste schwert der politik
im umgang mit der macht und
marktmissbrauch von großindustrie l ist
eine freiwillige selbstverpflichtung ich
muss sagen das nennt man eben das
übrigens einer der gründe warum die
erste wenige warum die spd seit vielen
vielen jahren mit volldampf aufs
abstellgleis fährt irgendwie und dort
noch jeden letzten parlament abreißt
weil sich hatte im kampf gegen die
unmenschlichen arbeitsbedingungen bei
tennessee auf freiwillige
selbstverpflichtungen er sein dass das
nicht funktioniert wenn man kann sehen
was sie eigentlich was denn sie kann ja
hallo kann ja sein das ist in diesem
fall viele freiwillige
selbstverpflichtungen haben übrigens in
der vergangenheit funktioniert
mag sein dass diese nicht gut genug
funktioniert hat wie man jetzt sehen
kann weil diese werkverträge immer noch
zur spanischen bedingungen die leute an
die arbeit holen insbesondere aus dem eu
ausland bin ich völlig bei ihnen bin ich
völlig bei ihnen die frage war aber darf
jemand ist es unmoralisch wenn es
pd ex-vorsitzender nunmehr den
moralvorstellungen seiner geänderten
moralvorstellung möchte ich sagen seiner
neuen chefs an der spd spitze
herr nowak und fresken nicht genügt die
sehen das anders das ist ihr gutes recht
dass sie jetzt auf ihren vorgänger
rumtrampeln finde ich ehrlich
unsolidarisch und das war auch mein
sozialdemokratische tugend den man jetzt
so hin zu hängen weil der mir überhaupt
nicht sympathisch ist und sigmar gabriel
wer so sympathisch ich kenne ihn
persönlich nur einmal gesehen ich fand
den super nett das ist überhaupt nicht
dass wir hier nicht von persönlicher
sympathie nein okay aber aber in so hin
zu hängen halte ich für nicht fair
der hat nichts gemacht was das recht
wird er hat er verstößt auf dem kundig
gerade gegen eine aktuell sehr starke
moralvorstellung hat oder moralische
aufteilung in puncto fleischindustrie
himmel wenn es eine pr-agentur gewesen
wäre
die 10.000 euro kriegt um den mann zu
beraten was wäre dann daran falsch
nichts in zwei fällen werden die wirte
die pr-agentur das auch nicht machen
tödlichsten nein das ist komisch dass
man ihnen dass man sie das sagen sie
ganz kurz manchmal für die zuseher
vielleicht auch interessant
sagen sie das jetzt nur weil wir hier in
der sendung sind oder checken sie das
wirklich nicht das würde mich jetzt echt
interessieren
man sieht dass sich an ernst dass sie
den unterschied nicht verstehen wenn ich
eine pr-agentur bin und ich werde
professionell da für das visual art
anwalt ja ein anwalt soll auch jeden
vertreten eine pr-agentur kann meiner
meinung nach auch bestimmten grenzen
vielleicht auch jeden beraten wie sie
sozusagen ihre botschaft übergangs finde
ich völlig in ordnung ist er im geschäft
sind mal gabriel ist nicht repräsentiert
aber nein
sigmar gabriel repräsentiert auch über
seine amtszeit hinaus ein stück
sozialdemokratische würde wenn sie
sowohl die nimmt er mich mit sozusagen
die behält er ja in der hand diese würde
sozusagen scheint es war als spd
parteivorsitzender als ehemann und da
kann ja nicht sagen so dieses stück
würde das tue ich jetzt mal in der
tasche und aus der anderen tasche hole
dich so zu sagen ich hab ich einen
geilen königshaus mit 10 mg hat ich habe
verstanden was sie sagen wollen ich
glaube ich würde das bestreiten
und ich würde es differenziert sagen wir
mal so und meinen das ganz ernst ich
glaube noch einmal das beispiel schröder
es gibt so was wie eine nachwirkende
würde des amtes kanzler meinetwegen auch
wirtschaftsminister oder arbeitsminister
sigmar gabriel kann darunter fallen
umweltminister war übrigens auch mal
kann darunter fallen
aber was ist glaube ich nicht gibt ist
die pflicht alles mitzumachen in einer
partei war sie für eine parteien
nachwirken timmer geradezustehen den man
ja in form von presseartikeln zum
beispiel jeden tag aufs neue bild was
sie alles falsch macht also an der würde
in abstimmung gestrichen als
sozialdemokrat als spd-mitglied würde
ich ihn nicht messen
wenn er dinge drehen würde die was mit
seinen alten ämter als wirtschafts oder
als außenminister zu tun haben dann ist
es okay aber sigmar gabriel hat sich
entschieden pr-agentur zu sein und zwar
per ärgern tour seiner selbst das finde
ich jetzt auch nicht gerade appetitlich
und ich finde auch vielleicht schenkt
dass ich da weg und zerstört sein ruf
den er hatte mag schon sein aber
unmoralisch empfinde ich das wirklich
nicht ganz so einen unterschied machen
für wenig dann tät ich bin sozusagen
weil für wen ich tätig bin mit den
identifiziere ich mich ein stück von dem
das geht natürlich auch auf mich wenn du
aber dass die hand sozusagen die
schüttler da bleibt natürlich auch ein
bisschen was bei mir kleben und herr
tennis ist hat der typ der gesagt hat
die afrikaner sollen aufhören bäume zu
fällen oder sand und im dunkeln und dem
dunklen kinder zu machen das war die
rassismus geschichte weswegen er bei
schalter echt ärger bekommen hat und ja
und das wusste man auch gut dass kein
grund für ihn nicht tätig zu sein ja man
das war einfach aber ich will damit nur
sagen er wusste natürlich schon mit
welchen leuten er sieht ja okay der
tennis ist das wirtschaftsblatt gerichte
dateien eine positive wende geriebener
marktwirtschaftler unternehmer oder
vielleicht auch halb seiten mit manchen
seiner methoden und seiner ansichten
alles geschenkt aber noch einmal wir
haben natürlich an der börse sieht
höhere ansprüche bleiben sie beim thema
natürlich haben wir ja das ist halt so
es ist natürlich so dass ist das ist
unfair da haben sie recht weil der
sozialdemokrat oder der der
linkspartei-politiker kann im grunde
nachher nur im vorstand vom altenburger
skatclub werden ja oder pablo haben wir
darum habe ich also oder sowas und kann
natürlich hat es in der industrie
natürlich schwerer weil dann leute man
sagen aber jetzt plötzlich hast du die
seiten gewechselt ist das seitenwechsel
sehr stichworten ist das so schlimm gibt
es ja klar die seite 6 hat jack
natürlich hatte sie sein will
aber ich frage ob das seitenwechsel man
sich so schlimm ist oder könnte ist der
politik mithin auch der wirt
mal ab und zu häufiger als es derzeit
der fall ist in deutschland zu tun wenn
der eine aus dem eigenen lager mal für
eine zeit lang ins andere geht und sie
zurückkommen mitreden wenn dann noch ein
bisschen länger bei hennes gewesen wäre
hätte der seine arbeitsbedingungen und
seine löhne verbessert wollen sie das
sagen das weiß ich nicht genau aber ich
finde zu sagen kleben wenn du einmal
politiker master 40 jahren zahlen auf
den bulgaren nicht fünf euro die stunde
sondern fünf euro 60 und clemens denkt
nach ja sieht man das ist eigentlich
recht dass mit dem fünf euro ist von mir
ja das ist richtig gemeint die mängel so
war ich sage ich sagen jetzt politiker
in die wirtschaft wechseln ohne dass er
quasi immer dem vorwurf haben bekommen
muss als sozialdemokrat offenkundig
doppelt auch noch von ihnen
du legst dich mit leuten ins bett der
ursprünglich als in ein lager gehören
dem dein altes politisches lager eher
kritisch bis feindlich gegenübersteht
das finde ich so kindisch das finde ich
wirklich entschuldigung das ist 19
jahrhundert da musste man oder 20 jahren
vielleicht da musste man dreckige
fingernägel haben um über armut redens
und wann haben sie beinahe magath und
kann von manchen anzuraten haben damit
man überhaupt leute ich dass wir heute
dieses thema besprechen das hätte ja
auch noch andere themen in dieser woche
gegeben aber ich habe mich ja wie sie
wissen sehr dafür eingesetzt dass wir
das thema machen weil es mich natürlich
interessiert weil ich glaube es ist ein
kleines mosaiksteinchen nur kleiner
staaten ja also das wohl und wehe der
deutschen sozialdemokratie oder gar der
europäischen sozialdemokratie hängen
nicht daran aber es ist ein kleines
symbolisches mosaiksteinchen was
sozusagen teil des weges ist auf dem die
sozialdemokratie ins abseits gegangen
ist das sieht nämlich sozusagen die
leute die bei tommys arbeiten nicht mehr
vertritt im vergleich dazu wie sehr sie
herrentennis vertritt und da braucht man
dann die sozialdemokratie gerade gar
nicht mehr erreicht die cdu voll stände
die von der form wie wie die spd spitze
in der breiten fläche auch andere
parteien nämlich andere gar nicht aus
herrn tönnies verteufeln gerade das
werden sich die arbeiter bei tommys
wahrscheinlich schon merkt also
dankeschön die schließen jetzt eine
ganze verbringen die bulgaren die dann
endlich sie herr demokratischen werten
sowie sozialen kann ich habe das gefühl
sigmar gabriel hat der sozialdemokratie
mehr angetan anderes angetan was
deutlich schwerer weg ich will das hier
ich wollte eigentlich den witz erzählen
von den zehn millionen in kleinen
scheinen die dann eingetauscht werden
gegen zehn zitronen in kleinen schweinen
aber
das kommt das nächste mal danke
[Musik]